[Applause]
calls himself the lion and Promises to
transform the economy if he becomes
Argentina's next president
the far-right candidate has been
compared to Donald Trump and is
promising to dollarize the country and
get rid of the Central Bank
we have a society full of poor people
while the only ones who have profited
are the political Elite
many young argentinians say they will
vote for Malay in the primary elections
we are tired of the economic crisis of
seeing our friends leaving which is what
many have done
initial rates towards the right
capitalizing on growing frustration with
traditional politicians the economy is
the main concern for people in Argentina
they struggle to cope with around a
seven percent inflation rate every month
the primaries will provide a national
snapshot of the public feeling just two
months before the presidential elections
in October
some familiar names on the ballot
include Sergio Masa the economy Minister
who's steering Argentina through a
financial crisis he's the only candidate
for the center left governing Coalition
and is seen as a close Ally of the
United States
the center right together for change
Coalition will be choosing between the
mayor of Buenos Aires oracio Rodriguez
and the former interior Minister
Patricia Ulrich
two strong candidates that are among the
top contenders for the presidency
there is a clear swing to the right and
the political office shows this it has
to do with the time it has to do with
the last decade where Argentina can't
find a solution to its problems in
general argentinians will seek the
center but politicians have failed to
deliver good public policies and this
generates a complex social environment
[Applause]
opinion polls suggest the chances of
candidates such as melee making it to
the presidential Palace have shrunk in
recent weeks
but his growing support base shows that
many argentinians would rather vote for
an outsider than for politicians who
have failed over and over again
Buenos Aires
foreign